greetings Nephilim and welcome to patch
210 my name is Brandi camel also known
as novelist asst community
representative for Diablo 3 and your
host for today in this video we'll be
reviewing our first major content patch
for Reaper of souls let's get started
our biggest feature is a competitive
system we're calling seasons seasons are
similar to diablo two ladders and offer
heroes the opportunity to play fresh new
characters from level one seasons are
considered a completely separate game
mode as a result seasonal characters
will have their own stash artisan
progression gold and Paragon levels you
can create both normal and hardcore
seasonal characters let's talk about
seasonal rewards many new legendaries
will be introduced with each season and
seasonal characters will have the first
opportunity to get their hands on these
items if seasons aren't your thing don't
worry once the season ends these items
will be added to the regular loop pool
so everyone will have a chance to find
them each season participants will also
earn one piece from a new and exclusive
transmogrification set every season you
play will net you a new piece from this
special set so join the fun and you'll
get to show off in style conquests our
new season only achievements they
represent a variety of challenges from
defeating malthael on torment 6 to speed
running the entire campaign in under an
hour conquests are available to both
normal and hardcore heroes so you'll be
able to tackle these challenges in your
preferred game mode conquests grant
achievement points that contribute
toward your seasonal total they're also
tracked on the regional leader boards on
a first-come first-served basis the
first 1000 players to complete a
conquest will be immortalized on the
leaderboards for that season when a
season ends your seasonal characters
will become standard hardcore or normal
mode heroes as appropriate rewards
you've earned during a season including
items Gold artisan recipes Paragon
experience and achievements will all
carry over any items left in your
seasonal stash will be mailed to
in addition two seasons were also
introducing greater risks greater rifts
are a competitive form of Nephilim rifts
featuring a progress timer you'll have
15 minutes to spawn and defeat the rift
guardian and faster runs will bring
greater rewards to enter a greater rift
you'll first need to acquire a keystone
of trials from a regular rift guardian
and then visit the Nephilim obelisk in
town to enter the realm of trials the
realm of trials is a small arena
designed to evaluate your ability to
defeat waves of enemies upon completing
this trial you'll receive an
appropriately challenging greater rift
key to create a greater rift portal
simply bring your greater rift key to
the Nephilim obelisk in town strong
enough to survive the trials greater
rifts are tracked by a new progress bar
that compares your monster kill count to
the time remaining monsters grant
progress based on their health and level
of difficulty so tackling those elite
and champion packs will have a greater
payoff than your average minion note
that monsters in greater risk don't drop
loop and the rewards for the entire
greater rift will instead drop off the
rift guardian at the end greater risks
are much more challenging and should be
played strategically when playing in
greater rifts please keep the following
rules in mind some resurrection and
teleport functions have been disabled in
addition you will be unable to swap gear
or skills while in a greater rift so be
sure to plan accordingly when you defeat
a greater rift guardian you'll be
visited by a new NPC named oshi if you
complete your greater rift before time
expires you'll have two options for
rewards a chance to add a rank to one of
your existing legendary gems or a higher
level greater rift keystone should your
time expire in a greater rift the rift
Guardian will automatically be summoned
while you won't be able to continue your
greater rift journey after the Guardian
has been defeated you'll still have the
chance to upgrade one of your legendary
gems potentially adding multiple ranks
at higher greater rift levels aim high
and you'll be greatly rewarded for your
efforts
to support seasons and greater rifts
we're adding leaderboards for each
system these leaderboards will allow
players to track their progress for
greater rifts seasonal achievement
points and seasonal conquests designed
to be informative in detailed
leaderboards will allow you to compare
your progress to that of your gameplay
region friends and clan members and each
type of board will track progress a
little differently greater rift
leaderboards will display rankings for
both hardcore and normal heroes as well
as seasonal and non-seasonal heroes in
addition you'll be able to sort them by
group composition including solo play
for each class 2 player 3 player and 4
player groups as conquests and seasonal
achievement point totals our season only
features these leaderboards will only
track information for seasonal
characters conquests and achievement
points are account-wide so while some
challenges may require playing in a
particular mode there's no need to sort
normal and hard core information
separately
while many items are being revisited in
patch 210 we want to highlight some
specific overhauls first off two-handed
weapons have received an increase in
base damage across the board this damage
will apply retroactively Lee and any
two-handed weapons you already have will
be automatically updated we've also
added unique powers to several existing
legendary items existing versions of
these legendaries will not be
retrofitted with these new abilities so
you shouldn't feel the need to hang on
to them
have you ever wondered what's on the
other side of that treasure goblins
portal wonder no more with patch 210
each time you defeat a treasure goblin
there's a small chance to leave behind a
portal to the vault this mystical area
features dangerous new enemies and
riches beyond your wildest dreams so
don't let that next Goblin get away
we've also added a new environment to
Nephilim rifts the cesspools the
cesspools were originally designed as
the sewers of Westmarch while we
couldn't fit them into act 5 for the
release of Reaper of souls you now have
a chance to explore this festering dank
environment in any greater or regular
Nephilim rift this wraps up our overview
of patch 210 while we've covered some of
the largest features there's plenty more
to discover in our patch notes so be
sure to check them out we also encourage
you to share your thoughts about this
update on the Diablo 3 forums and we
hope you'll join us as we gear up for
our very first season thanks for
watching and we'll see you in sanctuary